Welcome to Ear Biscuits, I'm Link.
And I'm Rhett.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we are exploring the question,
how has Ear Biscuits changed
over the course of 200 episodes.
200 episodes!
That's right, this is the bicentennial.
Yes!
We've been going
for 200 years.
200 episodes.
Can you say bicentennial
when you're talking about
just the number or does
it have to be the year?
Not anymore than you have
but I think you've reached the quota.
I've got a couple in my back pocket.
You know what, it's been
a pleasure sitting here
for all two, well, there's
been a few exceptions but--
You're saying it like this
is the last episode ever.
Sitting at this round table.
It's been a pleasure,
we're stopping at 200.
For 200--
Hope you enjoyed it.
This is a milestone so I
like to get sentimental
so in this episode, I asked
Kiko to pull some clips
that span the history of Ear Biscuits
to kinda jog our memory
of some things that
we've been through here at the round table
and reminisce, probably analyze,
and pontificate about the future, perhaps.
If you've been with us since the beginning
or if you've done what some people do is
and that is you get in late
but then you go in early.
Go back.
Go back early.
And you catch up, you've
known, you've learned
that what this show is has
evolved pretty significant.
Yeah.
So I think that first of all,
the clips that we're gonna
be playing are mostly...
Well not mostly, it spans the changes
but we are gonna spend
quite a bit of time talking,
hearing from some of those
people we had as guests early on
but then we'll talk about
what the show has become
and what we think about that.
Yeah, what does Ear Biscuits mean to us?
And I think we've got a
handle on what it means
to you as a listener as
well so the interaction
between those two things,
I think we'll land there.
Before we get into it, I just
wanna say I'm getting whiffs
of myself, this is not
the first time or the last
that I've done what I did this morning
which was, for the past
few days I've been rubbing
my deodorant stick sans
deodorant on my underarms.
You know how when it basically runs out
but you don't have a new
one so it's like I bet
I can't see it but there's
some deodorant on there
and I'm just gonna rub harder.
Oh oh oh oh oh.
How many family members do you have?
Five other ones including the dog
or six if Britton happens to be in town.
Okay, you don't--
My boys have deodorant and--
But hold on.
I've talked to you
about how big my house
is, I mean, it's so huge
to go down there and get their deodorant.
That's what you're going for.
Option number one
is to use your wife's deodorant.
That's what I've done,
that's what I switched to
and now I'm getting wafts
of this powder scent
that's literally giving me a headache.
I was gonna say something,
I was gonna compliment you but--
It's like I'm in a frickin'
baby powder factory.
I've never gone up to my wife--
Does she use Secret?
I think it's Degree
antiperspirant and deodorant,
powder scent apparently, not a sponsor.
The ladies like to smell like powder.
Well when I get close
to her, she also hits
that Mythical Number Nine
and that really draws me in.
Mythical.store, but this powder's not,
can you smell it?
I'm gonna waft my jacket.
I can't smell a lot
of things so I don't know if
I'm a great candidate for that.
It's a head sickness.
I'm having trouble with it.
I'm thinking about getting--
I like it.
And wiping down my armpits and just going,
'cause the past two
days I've been stinkin',
like the left pit, not the right one,
but I don't use antiperspirant
so today I also feel like
not only am I getting powdered up
but I'm also gettin' clogged up
'cause I don't use that antiperspirant.
And you know what, it will
negatively affect you.
Okay so--
One day of it?
Well I went--
We talkin' about cancer, aluminum.
No no, I'd say three days, okay,
I don't know if we've ever
talked about this on Ear Biscuits
but we had a friend
Nick who told us to take
the Old Spice challenge
which I don't even know
if the Old Spice challenge is what we
or he interpreted it to be.
Right.
But he said it was when
you go deodorant only
and you stop antiperspirant and he's like
after a certain period of
time, it varies from person
to person, you will no
longer need antiperspirant.
Now I will say that neither
of us are very sweaty guys.
In fact, and I'm not
saying this as a point of--
Braggadocio.
Yeah, I'm saying it
because Ana who did hair
and makeup for Buddy System
during a very hot summer
and then has also done
hair and makeup for GMM
for quite some time, she said,
she talks about how some
actors are super sweaty
and you have to take certain precautions.
They're gonna sweat through their stuff.
You have to give them special things.
And she's like you guys
are very on the low end
of sweatiness so maybe--
That's right.
This doesn't apply to everybody
but both of us took
the Old Spice challenge
with straight deodorant,
I would say within--
And I didn't even do it with Old Spice.
Yeah yeah I don't
remember what I did but--
I'll just call it the deodorant channel.
The deodorant channel,
it's a new YouTube channel.
Why did I say channel, challenge.
Because we're YouTubers.
'Cause you know, even when
you use antiperspirant,
if you forget to use
antiperspirant for that day,
sometimes you'll just be in the middle
of a non-stressful activity
and you'll feel like
a drip come down--
Or like a fountain.
Like a sprout, it'll sprout.
Since taking the deodorant channel ,
since taking the deodorant challenge--
Subscribed.
Since subscribing to
the deodorant channel,
I haven't had that drippage.
I haven't either.
Ever, until I ran out of deodorant
but you know what I was
doing, I made a mistake, man.
I made a big mistake.
I actually went to the
drug store to get deodorant
to re-stock and I think I do--
You got distracted by gummy
bears again, didn't you?
No I got like a couple of Old Spices.
I fall for their marketing
and the way they talk
about the funny stuff
that it says on there
and it's just deodorant,
at this point I don't need
the antiperspirant so I just,
any deodorant will work.
But there was this thing on
the top in the natural section
and it said, I think
it said magnesium-based
or something like that,
it was like no aluminum,
magnesium-based and it was
also, it had charcoal in it
and I just--
That's such a trend.
I don't have any need
for it, I just got it
'cause I was like hmm--
Cool, new.
Here's what I said to myself.
I wonder if there are some
circumstances in which
I still might need antiperspirant.
Let me test this out
since this doesn't, even
though I don't believe--
Even though for the past
four years at least,
maybe six since we've taken the subscribe
to the deodorant channel.
I don't think it's been
six years but and I
personally don't believe
in the aluminum thing, I
think the aluminum thing
being bad for you is bad
science based on the last time
that I looked at it but
why take a chance right,
so I used this stuff for three days.
Mm-hmm.
And then the reason I
stopped using it is because
it was so hard, it would rip
the hair under my arms out.
It didn't have the smooth,
just go across there real fast
so I stopped using it,
went back to the Old Spice.
That day, drippage.
Triple?
I mean trickle?
I don't understand--
My words are coming out wrong.
What's happening, I don't
understand how your body
is adjusting to this but it
was like my body got the cue
that it was okay to evacuate
water under my underarms.
Pooch pooch pooch.
But within three
or four days--
You're back.
I was back to normal.
Back to normal.
So I encourage everybody
to do that, you know,
unless you're just a sweaty person.
I do get Old Spice 'cause
I also fall for it.
I mean I gotta hand it to 'em.
It also smells good but they have a lot
of really good smelling scents.
But the one I get is Fiji
and the man reason I do it--
Oh I've had Fiji.
'Cause I've been to Fiji.
Now that I've been to Fiji,
every morning my armpits go
back to Fiji.
Hmm.
So I gotta go in for some more Fij,
you know what I'm talkin' about.
I completely understand that.
I gotta feed the Fij,
so I was self-conscious
about the powder, I'm glad to
hear that you can't smell it
but I'm sorry to hear
that you can't smell.
That's gonna really put a
damper, I don't wanna put
that damper on our 200th
celebration that we're
in the middle of.
As long as there's
nothing else to smell, I'll be fine.
You know you can access
memories through smell
and I had this whole thing
I was gonna bring and,
oh this is episode 47.
You would bring like
articles of clothing from past guests?
You know how we always snip off
a little part of their clothes.
Well we haven't listened
to these clips together.
We'll do that, we'll go on a joyride back
through Ear Biscuits.
But first, let's plug some merch.
I can't talk about this
Ear Biscuits mug enough.
Well talk about it some more.
When you drink out of it,
it's like putting a podcast in your mouth.
That's a great analogy
and I would also say
that I didn't realize until recently
that this mug is very large.
You're eating our conversations.
A lot of people don't
understand how big the mugs are
because we're very large people.
I saw that people didn't
like one to be big
so we were gonna downplay that.
No no, I mean--
They're so small.
What are you trying to do?
What are you trying to slip your mug,
you trying to take it on a
plane, don't take it on a plane,
just put it in the cabinet
and use it in the morning.
I love a big mug, there's value.
You get more liquid in a bigger mug.
I mean it's not a Thermos,
we're not talkin' Thermos capacity.
I'm just saying it's large--
I love how I made you angry
at them.
I'm just saying it looks
like a normal mug but it's
a slightly extra large mug.
'Cause we're slightly extra large people.
And I go through a full whatever this is,
Ear Biscuits mug of tea or
water at least every one--
This is 64 ounces.
It's like a big gulp.
If you wanna get a big
gulp, Ear Biscuits mug.
Go to Mythical Store, or actually,
Mythical.store.
Mythical Store which is at Mythical.store.
That's what I meant.
All right, I've got some clips that are
in chronological order,
so let's just start at the beginning.
Well this is episode three,
released on your birthday,
October 11th of 2013.
Oh so young back then, mid-30s.
I believe Grace was our first guest--
I had my whole life ahead of me.
But this is a clip of Shane Dawson.
Shane Dawson's still around
arguably more than ever
so let's listen to this very short clip.
When I was a kid, I grew
up on horror movies.
Not whore movies, horror, harrer?
Harrer?
Horror movies.
I grew up, that's all I
watched, that's all I knew.
Still that's all I watch really,
so I was so desensitized
to violence and cussing
and boobs and all of that stuff so for me,
I wanted to be genuine
and authentic with what
I thought was funny,
what I thought was cool
and I was into dark
humor and all that stuff
and I was like maybe
there's other kids out there
that'll like that too and
when YouTube first started,
it was those kids.
Now it's a little more
mainstream but back then
it was the dark, gothic kids at school
and that's what they thought was funny too
and one of my first
sketches was about phone sex
where I had phone sex with a girl
and she ended up killing
somebody, I don't know,
it was very dark.
And yeah, and that's just what I knew.
And then the moral was phone sex kills?
Yeah.
The moral was,
there's always, if you
think your life is bad,
there's always somebody out
there whose life is worse
than yourself and you should
appreciate what you have.
It was always like, the
morals were very, very loosely
tied to it but my whole
thing now is I look at it
like okay now my goal is
just to give five minutes
of entertainment to somebody who needs it
and if there's a moral,
great, if there's not,
at least they got five
minutes of free entertainment
and then hopefully now
just keep proving people,
like oh I can actually
direct because my goal now
which has been my goal since
I was five is to direct
so now I'm not really
in my videos anymore.
All my last hit videos I guess,
so hard nowadays to get a hit,
but my last couple good
videos, I haven't even been in.
My last couple parodies I wasn't even in.
Mm-hmm.
Just behind the scenes
writing, directing so
that's kinda my goal now
is to take a little step back.
End of clip.
You gonna say that every time?
This is us actually talking.
I'm not gonna say that anymore
because now that I'm talking
it seems obvious.
Why don't you just do,
beep.
Boop boop.
Boop.
So a couple of things
about that, I've got a number of thoughts
but I'm not gonna hog
all of the thoughts here.
The fact that--
Oh really?
He talked about five minutes.
Talk about giving somebody
a five minute video
and then also talkin' about
how it's hard to find a hit
and how it's, he's not even
in a lot of his videos anymore
and then he aspires to, very interesting.
To me it just shows you
that Shane's mentality
has always been experimenting
and he's always had
his sights set on
succeeding at this platform
which this may sound like an
overly simplistic statement
but if you don't commit to trying to win
at the game that is YouTube,
you will not end up being,
you may have a successful
sort of stint as a YouTuber,
but longevity in this
game is recognizing it
as somewhat of a game
that has to be played.
The rules constantly change.
Evolve or die.
And he's done that.
We talked a little bit
about his dark humor
which if you've been following anything,
you know that his dark humor
has gotten him into trouble
from time to time but I
think the interesting thing
about him saying that he
was moving into this place
where he was directing and
also not being on camera,
and then you think about six years later
where he's at now which
is still kind of directing
and producing but he
has re-inserted himself
into the center of his
content because turns out,
that's what works and also I
can't think of many examples
where that hasn't worked on YouTube
since it's so personality-based.
And also he's gone to
the opposite extreme.
He's not talking about five minutes,
he's talking about like
an hour and a half.
What is the--
Well over an hour.
His documentaries--
I think he's done almost
two hour length.
Two hour videos.
On some of those.
I'm just very grateful
that Shane is doing well
and is so relevant more so than ever.
Maybe I won't say that,
just as relevant as he was
in his previous versions.
I'm just so glad that there's
people who've been around
who know how YouTube used to be
and they're still making it work.
That gives us hope because
that's obviously what
we're continuing to work hard to do.
Stay relevant, stay on this thing so
I'm grateful for Shane because
from a selfish standpoint,
it gives me hope.
I was also very grateful
that he came on the show
because it's not the type
of thing that he loves to do
I don't think.
No he didn't at the time
and he still doesn't.
We should acknowledge that if Shane
hadn't done his podcast, I'm
sure we've said this before,
I don't know that we would have
considered doing a podcast.
It wasn't the only factor by
any means but it was a factor.
He was not only doing a
podcast but it was doing well
and it seemed to be able to
support itself financially,
there was a business model there.
Yeah.
'Cause we just can't justify
doing some, it was
speculative for a few years.
I don't think we were making
money off the podcast.
There weren't sponsors involved
in the very early days.
But the plan was that there would be.
And if you only listen now,
yeah Shane was the third guest
of many guests, at least
two years worth of guests.
Let's go ahead and go to another guest.
Episode 25 released on March 21st of 2014.
This is Colleen Ballinger.
She also played Miranda in
part of the Ear Biscuit.
She came on as Miranda and then she--
Left and came back as Colleen, yeah.
Yeah and I don't know,
I think this is gonna be
a Colleen clip, I don't know for sure.
You're obviously talented,
not only as a comedian but
as a singer and a performer
so how do you balance that when
you think about the future?
Are you like okay well,
I've got these two tracks.
I hope that Miranda will
keel over at some point
or I'm gonna take this all the way.
What are your thoughts?
I don't wanna kill Miranda.
I think Miranda will live as
long as people wanna watch.
She's gonna get pregnant and get--
That's exciting.
She's gonna go
through it all with me.
Are you pregnant?
This is the announcement.
I'm pregnant, guys.
Okay, you've heard it first.
I always wanna make sure because I wanna,
that's the key to our show
working is somebody's gotta
get pregnant on the show, well, I mean--
On the show?
There's another Miranda tweet.
That's another Miranda tweet, I know.
This is your fault.
Whoa.
And lo and behold, she did get pregnant.
She did.
Miranda got pregnant.
So that was a forecast,
that was a premonition.
So you did hear it first.
Colleen is pregnant.
You heard it first on
Ear Biscuits, it just,
it wasn't true at the time.
And you know, she has, and
the reason I ask the question
about are you going to kill Miranda
is you never know how
people feel about the thing
that everybody loves about what they do.
Yeah.
And the thing that everyone
has latched on, a lot
of times it was like,
well that wasn't even
supposed to be the thing.
Really what I want to do is this.
And she is, she's got a role in a musical.
Broadway.
Broadway musical?
What is it, Waitress?
That sounds right.
Congratulations Colleen.
She's gonna do a little
run there which is,
that's been her dream forever
and she's not doing it as Miranda.
Nope, and she got pregnant
and then had a baby.
That's usually what
happens after pregnancy.
Yep.
And then it was,
so a little boy that's
all over her Instagram.
So I would like to say
we broke that story.
Can I say that?
You can say that and I think
the thing about Colleen
as well, going back to 2014,
and I think this is
pretty much the case with,
I don't wanna get ahead of myself
but we don't have any
examples of like you remember
when so-and-so was really
popular and we interviewed them
and now they're completely off the map.
I'm sure we could come
up with examples of that
but we're not because we're nice guys.
But the way that her career has evolved
and how she isn't as
reliant on the YouTube game
as she once was because I mean
she's still doing very well.
She had a Netflix show,
she had a Netflix special.
Special.
That's out now.
And just her touring that she's done,
I'm sure that's gonna slow
down or has slowed down
because of the baby but so much touring
that was super successful
and now getting these traditional roles
that she's playing the worldwide game.
She met her baby daddy
on her Netflix show.
She did.
Yeah 'cause he was the
love interest on the show.
That's why you gotta be
careful who you cast.
If you're an executive
producer on your show,
you gotta cast somebody
that you wanna hook up with.
Lesson learnt, you
know, make those babies.
Casting.
That's probably illegal.
You can't, yeah, let's not get into that.
Yeah.
Let's say relationally.
If you wanna get to
know somebody, you cast,
let's just make it--
Well I'm not making it anything.
I'm not making it anything.
So you can say I'm gonna make it,
don't say let's make it 'cause
I didn't make it anything
to begin with.
Episode 29, released on April
18th, 2014, Troye Sivan,
and we recorded this one at VidCon
so it may sound a little different.
How many details can we get out
of your secret project
that you're working on
that you mentioned at the beginning?
Yeah, go.
I'll say it's potentially
the biggest thing
that I've ever done in my
whole life, like work-wise.
I've been working really,
really, really hard
for I guess just under a year now.
There's gonna be a big launch.
But you've written it.
Maybe.
It took awhile to write.
And--
Maybe I'm writing it now.
Can I see your palm?
Yeah, that's gonna help me.
Go ahead, but--
Okay yeah we've got the life line here
taking a left.
So it's--
It's a novel.
Is that an actual thing?
How old am I gonna be when I die?
It's an album, I can look at your palm
and tell it's a blockbuster album.
And Rhett, you nailed it.
Beep beep beep beep beep beep.
He did not say, he didn't really respond
to your prediction because he
knew it was absolutely true,
100% true and--
The look on his face which we did not,
we did not--
Have video.
Video that at the time was a uh-oh, yeah.
You got me.
Totally right.
His first major label EP TRYXE,
I don't know if you spell
it out, if you say it,
'cause I'm a dad, peaked at number five
on the U.S. Billboard 200.
Had another album since then.
He shows up to perform with Taylor Swift.
Yeah he is in a different stratosphere.
The music has kinda, the
music thing's kinda worked.
Kind of worked--
Congratulations.
For Troye.
And you know what?
All because of you, Rhett.
Up until that moment,
this is the thing I didn't wanna say,
it turns out that the thing
that Troye was working on
was not an album.
It was a claymation movie
that he had spent a lot of time on.
Claymation takes forever
and when I said album,
once the cameras stopped rolling,
once we stopped recording
he was like you know what,
it's actually a claymation thing
but now that you said album,
I should probably do an album.
And I haven't heard from Troye since.
But that's pretty cool, you know what,
I wanna talk about what we
think about this interview phase
of Ear Biscuits but let's
just get through a couple more
of these interview clips.
This next one, skipping
forward to May 9th of 2014,
this is episode 32 with
a comedy duo known as--
Is it Smoosh?
Smosh.
Smosh, okay Smosh, yeah.
The overall plan for Smosh isn't just
about Ian and I so our main
focus isn't let's go do a movie,
let's go be huge Hollywood
hotshots or whatever.
Let's grow the brand and
keep our comedy alive
in as many different forms as we can.
We have our gaming channel,
we have a cartoon channel.
We're trying to introduce
new personalities
that totally get our humor
that we think our audience will like.
They love all the Smosh games guys now
and they love Mari so those
have been some personalities
that we've introduced that totally get it.
So more of that type of thing too,
other Smosh properties.
Yeah, other people that we really love
that we know that our
audience will totally get.
Yeah 'cause we can't
create 50 shows ourselves
but we can create other
shows that other people make
that our audience can enjoy just as much
as they enjoy watching our shows.
I think that's cool.
Guess I just need to say thanks
for all that strategic development.
They turned a corner
at that point in terms
of casting, expanding the Smosh cast
to include everyone that
we know very well now
because they work in our building.
And then Anthony and Ian,
they separated creatively
and if you listen back to that podcast,
I think in hindsight you
can probably read into it
maybe more than was actually there,
but that's a valid
exercise if you wanna do it
to see if you wanna over-interpret
some creative tension
or just creative trajectory
being kinda splitting up.
And that was still pretty early in 2014,
it would be another, what, four years,
before Anthony left.
I don't know, if I would
have known that we would have
acquired Smosh and brought them in-house,
and given Ian the freedom
with his team to continue
to create as they have, I just
don't know how I would feel
doing that interview,
I'd probably be like,
that's why I can't be a time traveler.
'Cause I'd have this
weird grin on my face,
they'd be like what's wrong with you, man?
Well we had no point of reference.
Absolutely, I mean, I would
say that up until the moment
that it started to seem
like it could happen,
we had no point of
reference for acquiring.
You know what I'm saying,
that wasn't really,
it wasn't really on our
minds, it wasn't part
of the strategic plan.
But yeah, 'cause we've looked up to Smosh
for a really long time.
You go back to the very beginning.
Probably when we started
our YouTube channel,
they had to be number
one, it was either them
or Barats and Bereta.
No, they were number one.
Historically they are in the top five,
maybe the top three most
subscribed channels on YouTube
in terms of longevity.
Obviously holding that
title for a very long time.
Yeah, obviously PewDiePie
is up at the top.
Which we also have an interview with him.
We don't have a clip of
talking with Felix but--
But you talked about another
clip we're not gonna play
but I wanna talk about it 'cause
it is the Wassabi Brothers.
We had Wassabi Brothers on.
Yeah.
And we actually, whenever
we have a duo on,
we talk about their--
Creative dynamic,
relational dynamic.
All that stuff.
And just, you know,
from one duo to another,
let's talk about that and
how you work through things.
And when we started asking those questions
about how you work through
things and differences,
et cetera, with the Wassabi Bros,
it became very evident
to us and you can go back
and listen to the episode
that this didn't seem like
something that was gonna last.
And I would say that within,
it was less than a year,
might have been a few months.
Right.
They announced that they were separating.
Roi and Alex.
Roi's gonna do a bunch
of bathing and stuff.
Yeah, they both gone on
to be very successful individually.
It didn't seem like they had
necessarily the commitment
to be like this is us
doing this together or bust
and that usually is required
and even when you do have
that commitment sometimes
it doesn't work out.
Yeah I think that was April 30th, 2018
when that finally came to an end.
Like Link was saying,
the majority of the episodes
early on were these interviews
because that was the, we
probably have said this before
but we were really
influenced by Marc Maron,
WTF Podcasts at the time
and that he was interviewing
these traditional celebrities
and getting into very personal things
and this wasn't something
we had any experience with.
Also it's a little bit
odd, there's an odd dynamic
when two guys are interviewing
one person typically
on a personal level and so
it's kinda like, ah okay,
this is an interesting dynamic.
Probably don't need two
people to ask a question,
interview somebody where
75 to 80% of the content
is gonna be the answers
that this person is giving.
I mean, there was some cool
things that happened with us,
kinda bouncing things off of each other.
There's two different
perspectives applied to it.
But we both have a lot to say.
You know what I'm saying?
And so every once in
awhile, even back then,
we would work in one of these
episodes where it was just,
hey let's just talk to each other.
But when we decided to do the podcast,
we immediately went to the interview thing
because there were so
many people doing that,
especially in the comedy
world like you said
but no one was doing it in that deep,
kinda introspective, analytical, raw way
with YouTubers.
YouTubers.
So I was very excited
about that in terms of,
actually I felt like it was
collecting YouTuber interviews
as a time capsule and I'm
very proud of the interviews
that we did because I
do think it represented
everyone's story up into that point,
how they got to that point in being
so successful on YouTube,
and I do think it's
useful to still go back
and see that YouTube has changed so much
that a lot of the success
paths that they took
are no longer viable paths because
YouTube is a different
thing, it works differently.
Everything's different about everything.
But I still think it's a time capsule.
I know for the Felix interview,
it was very obvious to us
that he had never really,
to the level that we
were trying to get him
to analyze his own success,
really grappled with that.
And it was a combination
of somebody who was willing
to ask those kinds of questions
but also had the insight
into what they were doing because
it was what we were doing.
It's the reason that Marc
Maron's podcast works so well
is he's talking to
comedians and performers
and he's a comedian and performer.
Yeah and I think it
had to do with our age.
I think we were already old
in terms of the ecosystem
of YouTube and so, and we
had been doing it for awhile.
We knew a lot of these people
and they respected us enough
to say yeah, we'll come in and talk to you
and it took on a life of its own because
a guest-driven podcast works differently
than a talent-driven, I'm
using the term talent loosely,
where it's just two
guys who are gonna talk
to each other every single,
host-driven, you know.
It works differently
and it draws people in
in a different way so there
are people who are coming
into an Ear Biscuits
podcast because of the guest
and we kinda relied on that for, you know,
basically the entire
first and second season.
Yeah but like you said, well,
and I do wanna add one thing.
I do think that, there was
a question in our minds
I think when we first came up with
what Ear Biscuits was gonna be that,
do people wanna hear us talk for an hour?
Do we wanna talk for an hour?
We moved to the interview thing so quickly
that I just wonder if
we questioned whether
what we're doing now
where it's just the two
of us is something that would be viable.
I think we thought that we
needed the name recognition
of the guests to drive interest.
But like you said, we, even
in the midst of interviews,
we did pepper in some
episodes that were just
the two of us talking and
this next one, episode 42,
released July 25th, 2014 called Obsession,
we talked about your layers.
Mm-hmm.
Let's play a clip of that.
Rhett goes through a series of obsessions
like a fashion designer
goes through new outfits.
These are semi in chronological order.
Ultralights, chiropractic, crow hunting,
wine pairings, fossils and geology.
Crowned Victorias, barbecue, hot yoga,
juicing, paddle boarding, four-wheeling.
Now that was edited.
You don't speak that quickly.
No, I move at the speed of conversation.
That was the speed of an edit
and the list could have gone on and on.
I think that was the list at the time
and then we kind of unpacked
the dynamic associated
with it but what do you think
when you hear that list?
I think about, I'm like oh yeah.
Mm, yeah.
What do you mean mm?
Yeah, that's good,
that's good, ultralights.
I gotta get back on that.
Gotta get one of those.
Fossils, yeah, I just looked
at my fossils yesterday.
I did, I was rearranging
some things and I looked
at some of my fossils and I was like hmm,
yeah I gotta get more of these fossils.
Now you're adding onto the layers.
I think that's the other way, it's like,
we can add to this list
now is the other way
to look at it.
Well you know, I think about,
so the last two mentioned
being paddle boarding
and four-wheeling, off-roading,
whatever you call that.
Yeah.
Are two that we did together
and I think the fact that we haven't done,
we haven't gone on an off-roading trip
in at least two years I would say
and we've paddle boarded once
in the past six months maybe.
Right.
I think that it is indicative
of a number of factors.
I think it's due to a number of factors.
One, professionally, oh you
going straight white t-shirt.
I've taken my jacket off.
Professionally and we were just talking
about this yesterday.
We're always as busy as we've ever been.
Right, now we're not
currently in the middle
of shooting a half-hour
comedy while trying
to work GMM into it at the same time,
that's not currently happening.
But there's just so many
little things that we're kinda
keeping up with that we've got less time
when it comes to just,
there's so many professional
responsibilities,
but also our kids have gotten to an age
where they always have stuff going on
that you have to be a part of.
Yeah let's blame it on the kids.
Are you saying, I agree with that.
No I'm saying, I'm not blaming the kids.
No I agree, it is--
I'm saying there's things like--
They have so much to do
and you got two of 'em,
I got three of 'em and it's like--
I do not make weekend plans anymore.
I'll make weekend plans way in advance,
like okay I'm gonna go someplace
for my anniversary or whatever.
But I know that it's like well,
Locke's gonna have a basketball game
or he's gonna have some
practice on the other side
of town, Shepherd's gonna
have a birthday party
or he's gonna have to go to
this golf practice or whatever
and it's just a given that
at this stage in their lives
that they are going to have these things
that they have to do and you combine that
with the fact that there's just so much,
and even when we do go do
things like paddle boarding,
the last time we went paddle boarding,
we turned it into a day of brainstorming.
It was like hey let's
go get out in the ocean
and then let's go and
sit down and brainstorm
a bunch of ideas, ideas
that we're actually
currently working on
in one form or another.
But are you saying you
don't have any layers?
Your life is such that you can
no longer have an obsession?
I think that--
I mean the lights in the house
were kind of an obsession
but it's--
That, well--
It's more of an installation.
I would say that that is a--
I would say home stuff is
an obsession for both of us.
I would say the most recent
layer is just reading
horror novels.
I think that--
That's one you can fit in.
Getting, writing the novel,
looking for some inspiration
and then continuing to think
about where we could go
with that story.
I'd say that's the latest
thing is I'm consuming
a lot of thriller slash
horror novels but in terms
of things that require
buying equipment and,
I anticipate getting
more back into the art
of barbecue when we re-do the
outside and I've got my eye
on this grill that I want or whatever,
but it's not like, last
time I smoked a pork butt
for a large group of people, again,
I gotta plan it, I gotta
get ready the night before.
I gotta spend six to eight
hours on the day of like--
But at least you're home so that's doable
and you can still be a dad.
No but I can't sit there
with a piece of pork
if I gotta go to a basketball
game or take somebody
to a birthday party.
Yeah that's true.
You know what I'm saying,
you gotta plan these things.
Those episodes where we would just talk
the two of us and kind of share stories
and talk about our songwriting process
or specific dynamics of our friendship,
I think were rays of light of shining away
to where Ear Biscuits
could ultimately evolve.
And we were getting good
feedback on those as well
from you guys.
And I think that you had
a mounting frustration
with the interviews, more so than me.
Which is totally fine.
I think it got to a
point where it was like,
I was a little later kinda
making that transition
but ultimately we both
got to the point where
we didn't really have an appetite
for these in-depth interviews.
Especially when our appetite
for having more conversations
started to grow, we can get into
that a little bit more
later but I think as far
as the waning interest in interviews,
part of it was practical.
You're subject to these
people, guests showing up,
having to be booked,
having to pick people.
Are they the right kinda candidate,
do we wanna talk with 'em,
do we have things to say?
It was a whole thing that was very--
And for me personally, I was,
there were some guests that I was
personally less motivated to talk to.
I was personally less
interested in their career,
just being frank about it.
I respected everybody and I learned a lot.
I would talk, we'd sometimes
have people and I was like,
I really don't know
anything about what you do,
but I'm gonna take, we
would have a research period
so we wanted to ask informed questions
and we wanted to know
what we were talking about
and so there would be time
that would go into learning
about them, watching their
videos and then coming up
with some semi-intelligent questions,
and that process became a
little more like homework to me
about a subject that I
wasn't interested in.
And I think that just for me,
and I think you couple
that with the fact that,
like I said, we both have a lot to say.
We can fill conversation
very, very easily,
both of us.
Both of us individually
have enough conversation
in the tank to talk to one person.
When all of a sudden you got the two of us
and sometimes there was, there was this,
and I think you had more
of a tendency to do this
to be like, you had this very specific,
and we wouldn't talk about it.
You had a very specific
way that you wanted
to conduct the interview
and a specific line
of questioning and so there would be like
maybe a 40 minute period in a podcast
where I might just say like yeah.
And you know me, that's not my jam.
And so, that was frustrating for me.
Yeah.
'Cause I was like,
let's just talk, man.
We got plenty to say.
Yeah, you know what I think I'm realizing
or at least remembering, one of the things
that really changed for
me in terms of my appetite
for wanting to switch the show
and make it more about us,
I had this mounting guilt,
maybe guilt's a strong word
but I just, I had a mounting discomfort
over the course of a couple of
years of doing the interviews
because I would make it a
practice to push so hard
to get to something juicy, to
get to something meaningful
and introspective and new.
I took it as a personal
challenge to get past
what they would talk
about on other interviews
and really understand not only
how they became successful
but what made them tick.
If they went through any
hardship, it felt important to me
to give them an opportunity
to talk about that
because I just felt like
that's an important aspect
that a lot of people didn't see.
They see the success, they
see the smiles in between,
jump cut together.
But they don't see in
between the jump cuts,
and I really wanted to
give people an opportunity
to analyze that aspect
of their own selves,
and I did push kinda hard,
I asked awkward questions.
And that's actually not what bothered me,
but I think the mounting discomfort was--
We weren't doing it.
We weren't doing that.
We weren't sharing.
I think we started talking
about it, so I felt like,
if someone would have done
to me what I did to them
in the line of questioning
that I presented,
I would have been very uncomfortable
and I didn't feel like that was fair.
I still don't feel like
that was totally fair.
But I'm glad that this
venue and this table
has evolved to be a space
where we can process who we are
in a way that I was trying
to get other people to do.
And I think that, I definitely
recall people commenting
about that, like you guys will get so,
so much personal stuff from a guest
but we don't know a lot
about you personally.
Right, I'll play a clip.
I didn't mean to cut you off,
you can finish your thought.
That was all I was gonna say.
So episode 91, actually we
called it Let's Get Personal,
released on April 24th, 2017.
Speaking of Lily, we took her
in for just an annual checkup.
They had concerns, sent
her to a specialist
and then to make a very long story short,
she was diagnosed with severe scoliosis.
We get the x-ray, we look at this thing
and her back is like an S.
When we get in with the specialist,
basically the first thing he told us was
these are where her curves are.
This is what this means,
these are the facts,
this is what research has taught us,
therefore we are recommending
spinal fusion surgery for Lily.
We left the doctor's office, we went out,
we got in the van and
it was the three of us
and we talked about it some
more and we cried, you know,
all three of us cried.
Of course it was and it is very scary.
Yeah so that was I believe
before she went in for surgery
and then episode 95, The
World's Longest Treasure Hunt,
where Kevin came on
and told us about that.
Totally different format
we tried for a little bit.
As part of the intro I gave
an update on Lily's recovery.
We told her your back's
straight and she started crying.
The surgery went exactly how we hoped.
It went off without a hitch.
It came full circle when we
got in the mini van again,
leaving the hospital for the first time
and we all looked at each
other and Lily was like,
we did it, now she's at home recovering.
She's doing great.
But the fact that they went in there
and they put two metal
rods that they custom-bent.
They smooshed her spine
to be back no longer an S
and then they attached those
rods using titanium screws,
huge screws into her vertebrae.
You know how many people--
And then six weeks
after that she's fully
recovered basically.
But here's the thing.
Here's the thing what?
You said here's the thing.
You got a little insight
into, somebody do a montage
of me trying to say something.
Insert something into a Link story.
Kiki, you do that.
I thought you were talking to Kiko,
I was like why'd you call Kiko Kiki?
I understand now.
Kiki.
Not Kiko, Kiki.
Maybe that goes both ways, I don't know.
That's a good analysis.
So that was after we
had made the decision,
this was well into us making the decision
for the show to just be the two of us.
Yeah, yeah.
'Cause I don't remember
exactly when that was,
but yeah, well we started
saying that the thing
that's gonna drive the majority of--
March of 2017 is when we started.
Okay so this is very soon after that,
'cause we were like let's use--
No more interviews.
The thing, the stuff that happens to us
is going to be the majority of the fuel
for the conversations that we have.
Right.
We've talked about this,
many people have made
the same observation that
some of the personal stories
that used to be the backbone,
definitely the backbone
of Good Morning Chia Lincoln,
the predecessor to GMM
and then the early stages
of Good Mythical Morning,
very much driven by us having
conversations together.
That's where let's talk about
that and moving at the speed
of conversation, a lot of that
was actually originally GMM.
Yeah.
Mode.
And of course, for reasons that most
of you probably understand,
GMM has necessarily taken
on a different tone and a different angle
and that's why it's in its 16th,
it's about to be in its 16th season.
Because we made that
change and then we took,
we took that spirit and we
moved it to Ear Biscuits.
And I think that that was,
even from a personal health standpoint,
was a very important transition.
Because GMM is like a
playground for our personalities
in which we do things that
grown men probably shouldn't do
or if they're gonna do it you
might as well watch 'em do it.
And we have fun but it's
not about being personal
anymore than just hey,
this is us realistically
reacting to something in the
moment and we kinda have,
two best friends having a good time
but it's not two best friends
pulling back the layers
of their lives, that's not what GMM is
and GMM's not ever gonna be that again.
But we do have this, we
have this place that--
And GMM was never--
It was never that.
It was never a venue
to be as introspective
or everything we did was for
the effect of entertainment.
We would tell personal stories.
Funny stories.
We would tell
the funny stories and
I don't know how much
we talked about Ear Biscuits
becoming a place where,
I think the assumption was,
hey we can share some funny
stories when they happen,
at least at the top of
an episode before we get
into something topical, which we still do
on many of these episodes,
we kinda use that format when we're trying
to figure out what we're
gonna make an episode about.
But then we also expanded
it to whatever's going on,
when the thing with Lily
happened that might have been
one of the first things that
I was like, you know what,
I think I wanna talk about this.
And it was, at the beginning of that,
the first Lily clip it was
like, speaking of Lily,
and then I talked about what was going on.
But it wasn't the entire episode and then
for the Kevin thing, it
was like hey since I talked
about Lily I wanna give you an update
on that subsequent clip we played.
Right.
But it was,
it felt good to be able to
share and for us to process
as friends something
that was such a big part
of my life, you know, and
that's when I felt like
that level of honesty and
introspection was rewarding.
Just for us to be able to talk about it,
without even knowing how a
listener would respond to it
and maybe that's part
of what you're saying,
the more that we're
able to have those type
of conversations, it's difficult
for us to find the time
to have the conversations that,
where we're sharing things
about our experience.
When the, hits the fan, we
absolutely talk about things,
we don't wait to do that on the podcast.
That would be ridiculous.
So I'm not saying that.
For instance--
In addition to that--
It wasn't like I didn't know--
Right.
The update with Lily,
but I might not know what
you did on your vacation.
The funny story that you're
gonna tell about your RV
trying to get out of the driveway, well,
you're not gonna tell that to me.
In the same way.
Because you don't need to.
That can wait for the podcast.
And that's the Good
Morning Chia Lincoln part
of it was I'm gonna tell
you this funny story
about the RV, we should put
that on the internet too.
Two for one, but then
we're both gonna talk about
what these vacations mean
to us as humans, husbands,
fathers, you know, pet
owners, all of those things.
So the show started to,
it evolved, but it started
to morph a little bit and I
should just give a quick update
on Lily since we've talked about her.
It's been over two years.
We celebrated the two year
anniversary of her surgery
and she had been rollerskating
recently and somebody came up
and clipped her from behind
and knocked her on her butt
and then she fell on her back
and it was the first time
that we were actually scared.
Did everything just pop out?
Yeah, her whole spine--
Like Mortal Kombat.
No, she had some bruised ribs but nothing,
it just so happened
that her annual check-up
with the spine doctor was within the week.
So that put our minds at
rest when they do the x-ray
and say you know what,
everything is totally fine.
It's all metal-infused.
After two years--
It's stronger than
a normal spine.
Well the screws
that they used to put the rods
in, by this point in time,
it's like, it's totally become one.
Right, it's all grown together.
So actually in the first year or so,
there is a chance--
Of Mortal Kombat.
No, of the screws getting loose.
Right.
And them having
to do something, so we've
passed that milestone.
Her number are check-ups are going down
to where they don't have
to be every year anymore,
so it was a miraculous surgery
and we're grateful for it,
she's doing fabulous and she
has no physical restrictions.
And she has the scar that
still, she wears as a badge
of honor and it's like, when she has one
of the shorter shirts that
these girls are wearing now
where it's like you can see the belt,
I wouldn't call it a midriff
but if you bend over,
you can see a little bit
of the scar and it's like
I'm proud every time
I see it and I'm proud
that she's fine with a bathing suit on,
hanging out with her friends.
It's not anything she's embarrassed about
and she's had many conversations
over the past two years
with other people who are
faced with the same surgery
or a similar condition
and she's able to see
how she can, her experience
can enrich the lives
of other people and give them support,
so it was scary, it was
life-changing for all of us
and it continues to be.
I think, I have a...
I have a personal...
I'm annoyed by sentimentality porn.
Okay, I'll use, for lack of a better word.
Meaning I'm going to say
something sentimental
or I'm gonna do something
or I'm gonna share something sentimental
because I know that it
will affect the audience
in a certain way, and it's manipulation.
It's a manipulation thing and so I think
that there are definitely,
when you talk about vlogging,
personal vlogs where people
are like I've made a decision
that I'm gonna share my life with you,
I think you get into a
place where you start hoping
that you're going to
experience things that then
will make deep, moving material
that just grows your audience, right?
And I just wanna be clear
that that's not what we do
on Ear Biscuits.
I think that's probably
clear but that's one
of the reasons that we
don't only format the show
to be about personal things.
Because if we said it's always
personal every single time,
it's gonna be about what's
going on in our lives,
then you begin to script
your life for the sake
of the content that you're creating.
Yeah.
I think that's one
of the reasons that and
I don't have anything
against people who have
daily vlogs or family vlogs
but I would be lying
to you if I didn't say
that almost all of them
without exception annoy me.
And sort of, I think one of
the things that annoys me
about it is it's just like
your family has become a show.
And at that point, you
begin to make decisions
where the content is driving
the way you live your life
as opposed to the way you live your life
just being the content.
Listen, I understand, I can only imagine
what it would feel like to
be in that kind of cycle
and I'm glad that I'm not in that cycle
but with Ear Biscuits, it's
like if something happens,
and I think that just
statistically or circumstantially,
whatever, I haven't had
this situation happen with,
I haven't had that happen with my kid.
I haven't had a medical
situation with my kid.
I haven't had a close relative die
like your grandfather died.
I haven't had my mom's husband
who incidentally is my dad.
Hasn't been through a difficult time
in the hospital so Link has
shared a lot of those things
so I'm not saying Link is
doing sentimentality porn,
I'm just saying that as things happen,
if we feel that they're appropriate,
we're gonna talk about them
and we're gonna process them together
because we're purposely
choosing to format the episodes
in a way that gives us the
ability to share personal things
but doesn't make the point--
An obligation.
Of the podcast to be
sharing personal things
at which point I feel
like we would be hoping
that things would happen
or sensationalizing things
that are happening to us
for your entertainment.
And again, this is a business.
We do this in part so that we
can get money from sponsors,
that we can grow our business
at Mythical Entertainment,
that we would be dishonest
if we weren't transparent
about that but I think more than that,
it has become a place for
us to process the things
that we are experiencing and also,
just be like hey, we're gonna
be open about our lives,
we're gonna be open about
what it's like to be,
to run a business, to be a best friend,
to be a husband, to be a father.
As these things happen to us,
we're gonna try to accurately portray them
and just share our experience.
And I've really tried to understand what
my personal boundaries are for sharing
and what the objective of that is.
And I will say, I will
also acknowledge that yes,
you haven't had things happen in your life
since we've been sharing this
type of stuff on Ear Biscuits
that have had this headline
material sensational type thing
like the stuff that you
listed that I've shared about.
But that's not to say, I mean,
I couldn't have predicted
that I would have been
sharing those things.
If you would have told
me I would have said,
"I can believe you but I don't
know how we'll get there."
I don't know that you would have predicted
that you would be sharing
openly about therapy
and the things that you're
learning but I think
that it's to your credit, I think it's...
You're also doing that.
We're honestly processing our lives
and that's what this show has become.
It's processing our lives
and our perspectives
but I 100% agree that it's
not with an obligation
to over share especially to the point
of sensationalizing things
or hoping that something
sensational happens.
Right.
But in terms of my boundary,
even though we've done episodes
where they were advice-themed,
I never want to turn my
personal experience back
at the audience as advice.
I just wanna honestly process and then,
if I'm honest, then you
as a listener can take
whatever's valuable to
you, that's up to you,
but I try to be disciplined
to not turn my experience
into advice for somebody else even though
I do like givin' advice
and I like feelin' like
I'm right about stuff.
But I'm very grateful with the way
that Ear Biscuits has expanded.
I think that again, this
is not the primary venue
for us to have the deepest,
deepest conversations
that we have, but it's that middle ground
of conversation, being
able to tell the story
for comedic effect and us
to experience that together
is really fun, that's really
great for our relationship.
Yeah.
And also, when we get into
the introspective aspects of,
I told you the RV story, that was funny,
but then we're gonna
talk about our vacations
and I think we do get at things that,
it's that middle ground of
conversation that's kinda like,
you find yourself being
introspective at a point
where we probably would have just moved
onto working otherwise.
Right.
So I do think that I'm very happy with
where Ear Biscuits is for
that reason and then I'll say,
secondarily, I've been very encouraged,
pleasantly surprised that the
more that we have been honest
about our perspectives
and our experiences,
that listeners have related to it
and that it's helped them in some way.
Yeah, it's been one of the
most encouraging things
from people that we meet on tour.
Yeah.
And of course there's lots
of people who are like
the bright spot that GMM represents
in my day has been
transformative for me emotionally
and again, we never
intended that but the fact
that that's a reality is just
something that blows us away,
but I think that when somebody
says Ear Biscuits has...
This particular thing
that you talked about
changed the way that I approach this thing
or thought about this thing in my life.
Again, not from a hey
we're giving you advice.
Usually the advice that we give
is for some stupid situation
and for the sake of entertainment.
But just, when you hear
somebody talk about something
that there's a touch point in your life
and you're seeing how
they're navigating it,
that's just how humans relate
to each other, you know.
It's not like hey look
at me and do what we did,
but it's just like, hey,
I'm just gonna share honestly about this.
Any relationship and I do
think that it's not just
the relationship that
we have with each other,
it's the relationship that
we have with you listening,
anytime that you're just
open about something
that's going on, that enhances,
there's the opportunity for
that to enhance your life
and that's a responsibility
I think that we didn't design
the show to ever have
but I think it does now
and so we think about that,
when we're sharing something
that we're going through,
I think we're very,
very much aware that there
are individuals out there
who are going through something
very similar potentially
or will go through something similar
and if that can improve their experience,
then that alone makes
this whole thing worth it.
And from a content standpoint,
just to get a little more practical,
I'm very encouraged when I see,
well my heart sinks a
little bit when I look at,
if I see the Good Mythical Morning
or the Rhett and Link Reddit thread
and a new entry will pop
up where somebody says,
I miss the old Good Mythical Morning
or this is what I don't like
about Good Mythical Morning
or I miss Good Morning Chia
Lincoln and then inevitably,
the conversation very quickly turns to,
it sounds like Ear Biscuits
is perfect for you.
You know?
Yeah.
So I'm--
It's funny that, I don't know
how much we talked about it
and I don't know how intentional it was
but as Good Mythical Morning has evolved,
then Ear Biscuits also
evolved to fill a desire
for something that no longer
is the achieved dynamic
of that show which is just
unstructured conversation
that gets to personal
stories that are funny
and as we've discussed, it
goes a lot further than that.
I'm just, I'm glad to be
200 episodes into something
that we didn't get complacent,
but we continued to want to
express ourselves creatively
and to find a way to be engaged.
'Cause I think that anything that--
And then this is what happened.
You anticipate going for
an extended period of time.
As a performer, if
you're creating a product
that does require you to
perform on some level,
believe it or not, we are
performing in one sense
because we're not just
talking to each other,
we're having a conversation
in this context
where you're listening.
Anytime you can transform
that into something that
does not feel like a burden,
I think you're in a good place,
and not only does this
not feel like a burden,
but this feels like an outlet for us.
Yeah.
And I gotta be honest,
with the interviews,
they began to feel like a burden.
Yeah.
When I looked
at my schedule back in
the day, it was like,
oh you gotta do an Ear Biscuit
and you're not prepared
for that person, it felt
like ah, you got a test.
But when I see you've
got an Ear Biscuit today
on the schedule and even if
I haven't prepared for it,
I'm like ah, that's something
I look forward to doing.
It's a creative outlet
and it's a mental outlet,
it's an emotional outlet,
it's a lot of things for us
and so yeah, I'm grateful
for what it is for us
and I'm grateful for what
it is for you listening
and I just wanna thank you for listening.
At what point you started
listening, that's fine,
maybe you don't wanna go back
and listen to all of 'em,
that's also fine.
What's most important is that you're here
and that you enjoy hanging out with us,
puttin' us in your ears.
Thank you for sharing Ear
Biscuits with other people and--
Anybody that you know that
what this show has become,
if you think that they
would connect with it,
don't be afraid to tell 'em about it.
So what will the next 200 episodes hold?
We don't have time to get into that now.
Maybe we will at another
point unless you wanna make
a quick Troye Sivan prediction.
Episode 400, what will it look like?
Well let me look at your palm.
Oh.
You sure you wanna know?
Not if that means you
really have to come up
with something that's
gonna be underwhelming.
Well--
If you got something good,
yes, if you don't, let's
just keep it a mystery.
We'll keep it a mystery,
but I do have a quick Rec in Effect
I'm gonna leave you with.
This is one that Link
has a little insight into
because I shared this
rec with him yesterday.
And I shared this rec not so
much as a pure recommendation
that I'm going all in on this
because I have questions about this rec
that I want you to explore with me, okay.
Now you may know, we've
talked about this before,
Primitive Technology, one of
our favorite YouTube channels,
this guy somewhere in Australia
who does all this stuff
with stone-age tools, never
talks, there's no music,
never looks at the camera
and he just builds stuff
and it's amazing.
Well as you might expect, he
essentially created a genre
of YouTube videos and now
there are other people
following suit and doing the same thing.
There's a guy, I'm gonna say this wrong,
but his channel is Mr. Heang Update.
And I believe it's Mr. dot--
H-A-U-N-G.
No, H-E-A-N-G.
There's no U.
Heang, I think, but there's no space
after the period in mister either.
At least in the YouTube
channel, Mr. Heang Update.
And he's got a bunch of videos.
There's two from the past
couple months that he built
this under, well, this
is the confusing thing.
Link and I watched both videos.
Using a stick, he dug into a huge pit
and it's like this incredible dwelling.
He made a submerged dwelling--
That has a pool in it.
In the bottom of it there is a pool.
And he did one video, like
a 15 minute long video
where he does this and it's awesome
and then he did a second
video which included footage
from the same exact video, was
released around the same time
but then he put a roof on it.
Yeah and made it where you
couldn't see it at all,
it was like it wasn't even there.
Regardless of the nature
of how this all happens,
it is amazing and you should watch that.
But the assignment and
the question is what?
The assignment is
between those two videos,
I don't understand why he
decided to do one with a roof
and one without a roof, release
them around the same time
and include footage of
both things but also,
to go and look at other things,
I feel like with Primitive Technology,
every single thing that
he does is documented
and you know that he didn't get any help.
My question about Mr. Heang is,
is he really doing all this himself?
I want to believe,
I want to believe he's
doing it all himself,
but I have my suspicions
because first of all,
we know he has a cameraman
because the camera moves
when he's in the--
Don't give 'em the answers.
Let 'em look into it.
Primitive Technology doesn't
seem to have a cameraman.
But there's also many steps
in Mr. Heang's process
that you don't see.
That's the Rec in Effect.
I also highly recommend it
and thank you for celebrating
200 episodes, y'all.
Mm.
#EarBiscuits.
Let us know what you think of
the evolution of Ear Biscuits.
We'll talk at ya next week.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.